let's return now to Iran where this
supreme leader has delivered his first
sermon in eight years to attack the
United States and Europe in the last
hour the US Special Representative for
Iran Bryan Hook has said that more Iran
threatens the world the more isolated it
will become while mr. Hoek joins us now
many thanks indeed for spending some
time and talking to assert mr. Herk
firstly are you worried at all that
their killing of general Soleimani has
backfired on the United States and its
allies somewhat quite the opposite
Qasem Soleimani is the architect of
almost all of Iran's major terrorism for
the last 21 years and so it was very
important for him to be taken off the
battlefield he once famously said that
the battlefield as mankind's lost
paradise the supreme leader gave him a
medal as a living martyr of the
revolution he had a cult of personality
around himself he was very effective he
is responsible for the deaths of over
600 Americans and he injured thousands
he is also very much complicit with the
murder of half a million people in Syria
supporting Assad and creating a refugee
crisis the worst since World War two so
taking him off the battlefield makes the
Middle East much more stable the Iranian
regime has said that its strike on the
Iraqi base concludes the retaliation
Iran appears to be standing down for now
we hope the regime starts making better
choices in Friday praise this morning
Iran's supreme leader described the u.s.
precedence as a clown I mean that
doesn't really sound like a man who is
prepared to negotiate with US officials
well that was that's a mistake he
continues to make it's not just with US
officials look at the diplomacy that
President McCrone has launched over the
last many months since May Japanese
Prime Minister Abe a in Pakistan Oman
many countries have reached out to the
supreme leader asking him to de-escalate
he continues to choose the path of
aggression and as a consequence the
supreme leader is managing economic
collapse and the worst political unrest
in the regime's 40-year history economic
collapse largely contributed affected by
the sanctions that you are imposing on
Iran its Iranian people who were
suffering though not government
officials well that's not true if that
were true you saw the protests that
happened in November in thirty-one
provinces yeah the the deadliest
political unrest in the 40-year history
there was not one demonstration against
American sanctions President Trump of
the United States government they were
all against the Iranian regime and they
recently picked up over the weekend
after the regime lied to the people
about for three days about whether it
shot down the jetliner carrying 176
Iranians and so we know that there were
tons of experts that predicted when we
launched our sanctions that it would
have a rally around the flag effect
all of the experts were wrong but we
have seen a rallying around the around
the Iranian flags I mean you only had to
look at the scenes out of Tehran and
elsewhere in the country after general
Soleimani was killed to know that if
anything the population or large numbers
of the populations have been completely
unified behind Iran's supreme leader on
this I mean there is the arguments about
you know the protests that we saw
against the regime mr. Hoek but you know
what regime officials will say is that
let this is not point naught naught 5
percent of the population larger people
in Tehran this is a country with a
population of 85 million people
well I'm glad you asked about the
protest so that the morning that the the
protesters that came out after Qasem
Soleimani was killed I think the
government said that there were hundreds
of thousands of people in Tehran that
took to the streets Tehran has a
population of 8.7 million people that
meant 8 million people stayed home the
Iranian people noted on the output that
was saw in the streets a man responsible
for he is responsible for the Iranian
people know that the IRGC and the Kurds
force have been brutalizing them for 40
years Qasem Soleimani is the man who was
behind the murder of 1500 innocent
Iranian protesters in November thousands
were injured and over 8,000 people were
put in jail because of the IRGC the
Kurds force and the besieged forces the
Iranian people know their oppressor and
it is not the United States we've heard
president Trump speak a lot about the
nuclear deal over the last few weeks and
last few months I'd like to get your
thoughts on the current relationship
between the United States and the United
Kingdom there's a lot of talk about if
our Prime Minister doesn't pull out of
the Iran nuclear deal that could have an
effect on the trade relationship between
our two countries moving forwards I
don't have any comment on the specific
bilateral talks between the US and the
UK but what I can say is that US UK
relations are fantastic Boris Johnson
just a few days ago said that we should
replace the Iran deal with the trunk
deal and we since we have left the deal
a year and a half ago have made clear
that the Iran nuclear deal will not
prevent Iran from getting a nuclear
weapon and it will make it richer and it
also doesn't say anything about Iran's
ballistic missile testing its missile
proliferation its terrorism its regional
aggression and its hostage-taking which
is also a big concern to the UK
government so we're very pleased that
the ìiî have launched the dispute
resolution mechanism there need to they
will need to make their own decisions
and their sovereign capacities on how
that plays out but we're pleased that
Prime Minister Johnson has said that we
need a new deal and he said it a few
times
okay Brian hood US Special
Representative for Iran
many thanks indeed for him joining us
this afternoon thank you thanks B sorry